it is a little before five a.m. this is
the ferry terminal at Cebu hundreds of
queuing to make the hardest of journeys
no one here has any idea if their
families on the neighboring Island
survived the typhoon communications are
down and the pictures emerging a grim
the only way to find out is to go Ramon
Gerardo has made an extraordinary
journey to find his family like so many
Filipinos he works abroad and so for
three days he's traveled from Saudi
Arabia though Lisa I slipped maybe
though I was only thinking what happened
but it's happening to my family my my
relatives and all in tacloban city
leaders
the ferry is packed and with another
storm coming the two-hour crossing is
rough almost everyone here must be
feeling the same a mixture of hope and
dread there are supplies two boxes and
boxes of them for a place where
everything is desperately needed we've
only just got off the boat from Cebu and
already it's clear here at the Harbor
just how bad the destruction is take a
look at that and look at those trees
beyond this is all mock on the islands
west coast it looks bad and it is until
you begin the drive north and then East
we decide to take the journey with
Rahman at his request to discover the
fate of his wife and five children it is
an extremely difficult drive as each
mile passes the destruction worsens it's
hard to imagine ramones emotions finally
after four hours we reach the eye of
this storm Ramon's home Tacloban City it
is devastated
some 10,000 are thought to have died
here five days on the stench from the
bodies that still lie wrapped up on the
side of the streets is overwhelming then
as we fight through this health Rahman
spots a friend she out of chit oh oh huh
we good there's confusion you can boss
yeah whoa and then joy there ok so my
family's okay there okay this that's
fantastic they're okay if he's been be
able t but we have to see we have to see
them
there is still a few miles though
through this broken city before he can
be certain
then on foot as night falls he spots his
house that was my house which one what
no more rope Oh finally a moment we
honestly feared wouldn't come my report
they're aimin this is my youngest son
extraordinary emotional do not owe me a
second son one by one Ramon Ruiz his son
Louie Nepali Malala hey and then in the
shell that was once his house his two
daughters and his wife may away a family
unscathed and reunited against every odd
and be alone and Mark Stone Sky News in
the Philippines